Film Courage: Why do you want to make movies
to help people feel less isolated?
Phillip G. Carroll, Jr., Writer/Director of
THE HONEYMOON PHASE: I think one of my core
drives as a person is loneliness.
Growing up initially in school I didn’t
have a lot of friends.
I was bullied a lot.
It really drove me I guess creatively.
Filmmaking was the first thing that made me
cool as a kid.
It was like “Oh Phil is a filmmaker.
He can make movies.”
And it really allowed me to make friends because
kids wanted to be involved in making a movie
and being actors and doing cool things.
I really connected with that on a personal
level and knowing how hard it is feeling lonely
and especially as an artist too.
There is so much time that you are alone.
It’s very introspective.
When you’re writing it’s just you and
your computer and you’re writing a story
that is solely in your head and then pretty
much through the filmmaking process even when
you’re collaborating with people it still
ultimately falls back on you as the creator
and the decision maker.
Are you doing the right thing or the wrong
thing?
So loneliness is something that drives me
as a creator and a person and movies are something
that I think bridges gaps in culture and when
you’re watching a movie and you’re watching
characters you are feeling something and you’re
feeling you are connected to somebody else
and you realize that your own personal demons
are things that everybody shares and I think
that is really important to me as a filmmaker
is to be able to connect with other people
in that way and to show people that no matter
what you are going through in life, somebody
else is going through that exact same exact
thing.
Somewhere in the world somebody has the same
exact worry that you have and that you’re
not alone and that is really important to
me.
Film Courage: Did any of the people that bullied
you reach out and say “I say your movie.
Hey man, I’m sorry about that.”
Phil: It’s funny, I think all bullying situations
are different.
In my situation I ended up almost becoming
friends with some of the kids that bullied
me through…elementary school was the bullying
period and then in high school when people
started to grow up a little bit we were able
to develop some sort of friendship and in
my situation I realized that I don’t think
they realized what they were doing was as
harmful as it was.
I think young kids can be mean to each other
without realizing the damage that they’re
doing.
So I don’t hold any of that against anybody
that did it because they were young, they
were teens.
Yes you know right from wrong but you don’t
have a concept of how much impact you’re
leaving on people so I try not to hold that
against them.
Film Courage: That’s good.
And it helps when you grow up and have a good
right hook, too.
Phil: Films are my right hook.
I can tell those impactful stories.